you have to stand for something if you
want to have success as a business owner
then you have to stand for something you
have to find something to make you
differentiate yourself something that
you believe in something that makes you
special or you're going to get lost in
the shuffle hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hunger entrepreneurs
deserve help and yesterday I was having
coffee with a friend of mine named rich
and rich is an awesome photographer he's
a celebrity photographer he shot lady
gaga whole bunch of celebrities his
pictures are awesome they have an edge
to them they're funky there sexy their
urban they're different I've never seen
a photographer take pictures like the
way which does it and then he's saying
hey I'm trying to get new new business
I'm trying to get referrals and so I
said well bridge like what's your
message what do I talk about and if I
look at his signature even as an example
it'll say rich company information
photographer and entrepreneur and as he
promotes himself he says well I'm a
photographer are you kidding me i'm a
photographer rich you're you're crazy
good you're not just a photographer you
have style you have an edge you're very
different you have a specific target
market you're going after you've got to
express that I can look at rich's
pictures and see their different than
any other photographer that I've ever
seen but I don't know how to describe it
I don't know why his pictures are
different other than when I see it I
know they're different it's up to him to
explain to me what makes his company
different what makes his pictures unique
what is so special about his service
what does he stand for if you want to
get referrals you have to make it easy
for people to talk about you for me to
talk about rich I don't know what to say
besides which is a really great
photographer he has a unique angle and
he's a great guy that's not a solid
referral I need to be able to pass on
how amazing his pictures are and
describe it in a way that other people
can understand and if I'm struggling to
be able to talk about his business
then I'm not going to do it you have to
make it easy for your customers for your
referral partners for everybody that you
meet to be able to quickly explain what
it is that you do and why you're great
you have to start by standing for
something and a lot of us already have
it rich has it he can't communicate it
yet he's gonna work on that he can't
communicate it yet but he has something
different so you need to find something
different you have to stand for
something and then make it easy for
other people to talk about you if you're
not getting referral business it's
either because one your product or
service sucks and you're not doing a
great job service in your clients if
that's the case you got a lot of work to
do or two you're not making it easy for
people to talk about you if you're a
photographer if you're in a really
competitive industry which most of us
are just saying your photographer does
not make me want to spread the word
about you i know tons of photographers
why am i going to talk about you what's
so special unique and different about
your company you have to find a way to
stand out to stand for something and
incorporate that into all of your
messaging dumb it down to one sentence
that is powerful that makes it easy for
people to share your message and then
you'll get more exposure and you'll get
more leads and you get more referrals
because you're making it easy for people
to talk about you good luck if you like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below I'd also love to hear from you if
you want leave a comment under the video
the comments make my day guys I love
seeing those come in if you have a
question for your business please leave
it in the comment section below and I
might make it really reply for you so
thank you guys i'll see you soon